if you have
gestational diabetes during your
pregnancy
the level of sugar in your bloodstream
is higher than normal
the sugar in your blood is called
glucose
a hormone in your body called insulin
acts like a key in a lock
when it attaches to receptors on your
cells
the insulin opens your cells so glucose
can enter them
now your cells can use the glucose to
produce the energy they need
to function properly
a gland called the pancreas makes all
the insulin your cells need
to use glucose
the exact cause of gestational diabetes
isn't known
however the organ that attaches your
baby to your uterus
called the placenta makes hormones that
may prevent insulin from letting glucose
into your cells
as a result the glucose in your blood
rises above normal levels
in a condition called hyperglycemia
hyperglycemia is the hallmark of any
type of diabetes
if your blood glucose levels are not
kept in the normal range
you may develop complications such as
high blood pressure
in addition you have an increased risk
for premature birth
and cesarean birth in which your doctor
delivers your baby
through an incision in your abdomen
your baby may also be at risk for
complications shortly after birth
including excessive birth weight called
macrosomia
low blood sugar called hypoglycemia
a yellow color of your baby's skin
called jaundice
and difficulty breathing
gestational diabetes usually goes away
after your baby is born
the goal of treating gestational
diabetes is to keep your blood glucose
in your normal target range
you can do this by creating a healthy
eating plan with your health care
provider
or a registered dietitian
physical activity and exercise can also
help you keep your blood glucose level
within your normal target range
your doctor may ask you to regularly
check your blood glucose level with a
glucose meter
to check your blood glucose level you
will insert a test strip
into your glucose meter
then you will stick your finger and
place a drop of blood onto the test
strip
the glucose meter will measure and
display your blood glucose level
if you have gestational diabetes the
american diabetes association
recommends the following target ranges
for blood glucose level
95 or less before a meal
140 or less one hour after a meal
and 120 or less two hours after a meal
check with your doctor for your specific
target range
if diet and exercise are not able to
keep your blood glucose level within
your normal target range
your caregiver may prescribe insulin for
you
and show you how to give yourself
insulin shots
you can help prevent gestational
diabetes by
getting pre-conceptual counseling in
which you meet with your obstetrician
before you get pregnant to plan a
healthy pregnancy
losing excess pounds before you get
pregnant
getting regular exercise before and
during your pregnancy
and eating healthy foods